We're an omelet do I believe my legs. I'm
But it's like every day just got a burger. That sounds good. Yeah, oh man. Oh my God I
Think that's and samuel wait who Tim's dog nathaniel [I]?
Think I'm Gonna say hi
No, ali just stay here. No. I shouldn't I know but I'm just gonna do it so quickly okay. I promise. I'll be right back
May then hi. It's good to see you. You look good
Are you still doing that thing where you curl up on the green pillow I?
Love that pillow too
Well, I got that promotion
You always believed me so much
Yeah, you're right I
Didn't forget lies how hard this would be for me
I just really miss you and was just [wondering] if you'd be okay if I could pick you up
She does um well does she scratch behind your ears when you she does?
I don't want another dog nathaniel. I want you who's a good boy. Oh, who's a good boy
I'm sorry that was inappropriate
Sometimes I'm sitting on my couch watching Netflix, and I looked down and my hands just doing this there's nothing there
What if I just paid you real quick for all times sake?
oh
You so much oh
Tim hey hey good to see you you too. Have a good day
Lady like is moving to our own new channel. You're going to find more of the great videos you love click huge subscribe